字幕志愿者 杨茜茜
字幕志愿者 李宗盛
欸?
怎麼大家都講晚上好
晚上好 晚安
晚安 晚上好
夏威夷風的上衣
有點縮水的上衣
各位好
哇 這個看起來都是
呃 都是蠻熟悉的面孔喔
小李清風大輝
看一下
空中飛翔
陳秀民
有幾個蠻常見的
今天儲置神器又有優惠啊
沒錯
我們今天還是要講一下儲置神器
因為儲置真的還蠻好做的
那各位還記得我們的
第一次儲置的課什麼時候嗎
我大概
從3月20號開始做
3月20號
3月20號開始做儲置
那我大概用這個康和的戶頭
康爾的戶頭
來看一下
等一下我把它連到我的手機一下
我連到我的手機
desk in一下
這個軟體呢叫做
desk in
這個
我沒有業配
所以就
就
沒有業配就沒有那個
沒有優惠嘛業配沒有優惠嘛來看一下這個這裡啊 這邊是我的手機的螢幕
避免人家說你是騙人的
來來來 康和的嘛
康和 各位看齁
這是大概3月20號啦 3月20號開始做
對吧 3月20號
所以這個 這不是P圖好不好
P圖是不能改日期的
好奇的
這不是P圖
那我們來按一下查詢
查詢它就會跑出來
我的所有的金額
那各位看一下喔
3月20號開始嘛
64425340497777
還有一些可轉在
Wa la la
那
來看一下喔這邊
8200多嘛
這是交易假金就是
他要給我8000多萬
然後往右邊也花
出來了
就是我這段期間賺了8600了
那現在庫存的以實現還是正的
庫存的
庫存的以實現
目前還有賺400多萬
庫存的花快一點
因為免得被狙擊
我庫存以實現還有400多
所以加起來應該是可以到9000多了
可以到9000多了
所以
所以這個目標看能不能
這個月破億啊
然後被動元件呢
就我們所說的
已經有稍微回頭了
已經有浪子回頭的跡象
今天有些被動元件
被動元件我們之前就講了
它會有浪子回頭
被動元件呢會有浪子回頭
來來來看一下
他會有浪子回頭
那今天有很多股票有浪子回頭
有維田啊
新唐
新唐這個還不錯啊
新唐其實已經有跌過一次了
有跌過一次
有跌過一次我已經撿過一次
然後他又反彈
新唐有跌過又反彈
合金儲滯後跌
合金我昨天有空蠻多的
我有空合金
我有做合金
我今天的戶頭裡面
我就有合金的虧損
我看一下
今天的戶頭裡面有合金的虧損來來來我們來看一下今天的喔6月2號查詢6月2號我賺了200多萬
200多萬裡面應該有合金
合金的保訓
有有
合金賠14萬
有沒有看到這裡賠14萬
這裡賠14萬
那這邊賠14萬呢
為什麼
因為我在做套利
合金我是做套利的
我會用心金賺這個戶頭做點套利
就是我用他買一些
現股然後
買現股啊然後
然後空股期
買現股空股期啊
所以買現股空股期
現股賠錢沒差嗎
股期賺錢就好了
我的股期賺錢就好了
所以我也不care我的現股賠錢
但是該砍就砍啊
該砍就砍啦 因為他合金今天有跌停嘛
那我這個先來講一下
最近虧損的股票好了
我們今天要講虧損的股票
就講了一檔叫3532的台勝科
那台勝科為什麼虧損呢
因為台勝科在這邊進入20分鐘嘛
那進入20分鐘之後呢
他就連續漲了兩天
進入20分鐘之後呢 連續大漲兩天
那這種狀況呢是
其實也不會說沒看過
其實常常遇到
尤其是今年
今年最常遇到
今年其實盤是非常的強
所以呢常常遇到那種
20分鐘也不怎麼低頭的股票
常遇到啦 其實常遇到
我都遇到很習慣了
那遇到這個
這天
這天這個
這個被軋漲停
我在這天做了一個動作
這個動作我覺得蠻重要的
我在這一天呢做了兩件事
就是第一件事呢
我看
我看股期
所漲停之後
我盤錢立馬
全部回補
我的空單全部回補
再跟各位講一次
你做股票停損10%
那成本是非常的低
再講一次喔
你停損10%成本很低
你假如停損50%那成本很高停損50%成本很高因為停損10%你再賺11%就回來了啊停損10%你再賺11%為什麼因為停損10%你再賺11%就回來啦停損10%你再賺11%就回來
那但是呢 你停損50%喔
你要賺一倍才能回來
所以停損10%我是很樂於停損的
樂於停損
非常樂於停損 大不了就停損啦
所以我在這一天呢 我記得
我一共買到了10張
我記得買到10張
就是我盤中掛3張
盤中中3張
因為我買我空了30張
盤中中了3張
然後呢盤後中了7張
盤後中7張
我還有動用康兒的戶頭去幫我買個盤後
所以這邊呢
一共中了10張
所以我的20張呢
隔天繼續
那隔天在這裡呢
我又中了3張
又中了3張
所以我的虧準剩17張
在隔天這個位置齁
我直接做什麼事啊
在這裡呢
我直接
空
這個期貨
直接空期貨
那這個期貨是值得空的啦
來看一下今天挑選鼓起小幫手
台勝科呢
各位看一下台勝科喔
這裡 台聖哥3532
這裡
台聖哥今天的盤中呢
是有
有先漲停的
那我看那個試戳
我就覺得試戳其實沒有那個
試戳我覺得
我覺得沒有很強啊
沒有很強 所以我猜今天賣壓蠻大的
而且昨天
重點是昨天的
環球金已經殺尾盤了
好 各位看一下
昨天環球晶的長相長怎樣
這是昨天的環球晶
昨天的合金長怎樣
昨天的合金也沒有很強
環球晶也沒有很強
所以呢同類型的台聖科
今天補跌的機會其實蠻高的
我覺得補跌機會蠻高的
所以我就
我今天就直接
直接在盤前直接空了台聖科
台聖科空漲停欸
火空漲停喔 啊我有貼在這個
本磚上
這漲停蠻不容易的啦 蠻不容易為什麼你知道嗎
因為 那個通常
古奇的人比較厲害啦 所以古奇要空到漲停的
不大容易
來看一下
這裡齁
這邊
我就 我這邊空到了
空到了3比
空到3比 然後呢
有回補一比在這313
大概在這邊補到的
然後到了這邊呢
這邊的人是受到假戳的影響
這邊有人在做假戳啦
我們從這個明細可以看得出來
假戳就是他會在最後5秒鐘呢刪單
啊這個人刪在最後10秒鐘
他就刪單
他原本掛大單去買
然後在最後10秒鐘刪掉
他就不買了
所以呢導致怎麼樣
所以導致這個
在這個位置
這個看起來要大量打開的事實上是騙人的
騙人的喔
所以說這種跌停板掛大量的假說
騙了一堆人上車
今天這些人喔
今天這些人很多是以為
在講一次喔
今天有很多人以為台聖科要打開而去買
有很多人以為台聖科要打開
因為那個量看起來有點
看起來要開的樣子嘛
所以統一呢可能以為啦
我不曉得他是以為還是他是真的想要買
那凱基基隆可能是以為要打開了去買
國票可能是以為要打開了去買
所以這邊有一堆
以為要打開了去買
然後呢
我是在做套利
我在這邊呢又再做一點套利
這邊還可以做套利
那我可以做套利喔 因為我可以回補在這邊
然後上面可以空一些
上面可以空一些
好
那這些呢 這個
呃
看一下
這些
這個假戳的喔 我們都說希望他不會停電
不會停電
好 那
那這些喔 這個處置是這樣的
我們來解釋一下什麼是處置好了
好了
主制呢
還是很多人不大清楚我大概解釋一下主制是這樣子的就是當股票呢只要短線漲多這邊就會有注意注意注意
有沒有看到這邊有很多注意
那注意多了之後呢
他就會變處置
那處置呢他就容易跌
容易啦沒有一定齁
容易不是一定
那跌多了呢他又容易漲
所以處置呢又容易跌
跌多了又容易漲
那儲置呢就容易跌 跌多又容易打
所以這邊呢就是
我是覺得他有很多交易的機會
很多交易的機會在裡面
所以呢我們就把這個特性
從如何預測
我們講一下喔 我們的儲置成績這樣子
我們是去如何預測
他
會漲 會 會 進儲置
我們先預測它會進處置
然後基礎處置策略呢
它最簡單的就是
找浪子回頭的點
那進階處置策略呢
它就有很多啦
因為它有雙刀可以看
有雙刀可以看
那什麼叫雙刀呢
給各位看一下
好 什麼叫雙刀
我就來找一下
找一下
找一下 這邊
這裡喔
這個是
明天要被關的股票
喔 我明天華新科又要被關了
明天華新科又要被關了
因為他是20分鐘進入20分鐘
所以這個影響
影響的
就沒那麼大
那利隆店也有可能被關
那新鮮是一定被關
這裡啊
哇 群創被關
群創是7重5
那什麼叫7重5呢這邊有寫
我們就來看一下群創他的
他的規則啦他的規則是這樣子的
就是
這個10天裡面呢有7天
10天裡面有6天
注意的話
那麼他就會
有6天注意的話他就會被關
有6天要1到8款
要1到8款喔
所以我們來看一下喔
這邊有第二款
第四款
第四款第四款然後這裡呢第13款這不所以呢 我們按照這邊算1234567
7天呢 裡面有5天
所以呢 他現在呢
這個 我們來看一下
他現在叫7中午
群創呢 是7中午
那我跟各位講
7中午呢 代表說 未來3天
只要再有一天 他就被關
所以群創被關的機率也蠻高的
也蠻高的齁
這邊可以看他這個會不會中
那彩晶呢
哇彩晶明天肯定被關20分鐘了
肯定被關20分鐘了
好那以上呢是這個
儲治的日報
那我們再來看一下
這個儲治坐牢中的股票
好
那我平常我都會看一下
有沒有累計漲幅低到高啊
因為儲置而跌比較多的
現在有利英豪啊 佩亨啊 環球金啊 合金啊
這幾個玉邦啊
這幾個最近有稍微跌下來
那我們來看這個
欸
我們來找一下
找一下今天的
跌幅 跌幅呢就是漲幅低到高
我們看台勝科
台勝科 距離出關還有7天
最快在4天有可能20分盤
你看這邊就寫得很詳細
然後雙刀戰法呢我們就看到
他跟第一名環球金配對
那各位看一下
昨天因為環球金有殺
那台聖科
還漲停嘛
台聖科漲停環球金有殺
所以導致這個筆值啊
這個筆值是
台聖科除以環球金
那這個比值呢 就因為
那個台車哥數以環球金太高了嘛
所以他就容易
君子回歸嘛 所以今天台車哥為什麼敢控
為什麼
因為
因為今天我敢
我要敢控的原因是 我可以跟環球金來做雙刀啊
我可以跟環球金做雙刀嘛
那看起來他就是要跌嘛
對不對 所以你看 你假如今天跟環球金做雙刀
那這個就很漂亮喔
今天你跟環球晶做雙刀的話
因為我們是賭他這條線往下
那今天你這個做法就非常的漂亮就正確啊 因為今天環球金的走勢就比台聖科強很多嘛你懂嗎 台聖科強很多
為什麼是台聖科除以環球金而不是反過來
你也可以反過來啊
你也可以反過來 都可以
只是在這個畫面是
台聖科除以環球金 這樣而已
這畫面是台聖科除以環球金
你也可以環球金除以台聖科啊 也可以啊
一樣意思啊 一樣意思
這兩個是一樣的
所以呢
我們做股票呢
別人做股票
可能靠的是
運氣
運氣嘛
基本面
那我們做股票靠的是科學
我們靠的是統計
好不好
那我們就把這些統計的方法呢
我們就
放入了進階處置策略
裡面有很多進階的處置策略可以做啊
那還有做雙刀戰法
那重點我們有每月十戰陪跑
因為這個每月十戰陪跑我覺得這個就
蠻值錢的啦
這至少告訴你最近的一些心得
那我們還有專屬討論的群組
那他們自己在聊天比較多啦
我比較少出現
就偶爾我會貼
但是我盤中是不會貼的
好不好
我盤中是不會貼的
盤中是不會貼的
那這邊呢
這個完整套裝的價值
巴拉拉
有這個
呃
外面客很貴
我們這個是還陪跑了
欸
陪跑到
陪跑到年底
所以呢
他才會有這個
24小時的限時方案
喔
欸
軟體加課程
加送一個月軟體權限
買web
送app
送APP
買一送一
應該是買APP送web吧
反正這個我們之後有
APP有那個網頁版
有網頁版
那以後他們會漲啦 因為
因為他們
在這邊耗了非常大的心力
上次呢有一檔股票
不曉得各位記不記得
叫做國聚
那國聚呢在這個點位
在這個點位齁
一堆人都算他會被關
他被關20分鐘
哪一天啊我看看
好像是
我忘了哪一天
好像
1 2 3 好像這一天嘛
欸這一天啊這一天
很多人在這一天喔
這很多家軟體都算他會被關
那結果在這一天他沒有被關
他沒有被關
那沒有被關就繼續搶啦
所以這個算有沒有被關這個事情
其實是我是覺得難度蠻高的
因為他有時候會有一些豁免條款
所以呢他現在研究豁免條款研究的很透徹
那未來呢未來這個理財寶說
理財寶說 他們要打造盤中
會改變聽牌的數字
現在沒有人在做盤中改變
因為它會跟同類型 同族群的本益比有關
那同族群的本益比呢
就會跟盤中的股價有關嘛 對不對
那所以盤中的股價
一般的軟體是沒有在幫你測的啦
沒有在幫你測的
前一天幫你寫
儲置日報就不錯了
還幫你測
所以一般都沒有在寫的
那這個理財寶他目標就是盤中可以做得出來
他可以預測得出來
所以我覺得這個
這個蠻神的
所以他們未來可能會漲價吧
這是理財寶的政策就是這樣子啦
好 那被動元件最近很強
你看這個很強
那很強呢 各位記得
被動元件呢 其實
有些股票
他已經有回頭了喔
像信倉店 有沒有
這個是有回頭的跡象
我今天這個210
210幾我就有買
210幾啊
各位看一下
今天這210幾這地方我有買
因為我覺得
他看起來就是
看起來好像要噴要噴的樣子
我不知道啊 我不知道會不會噴啊
看起來就是有機會
好
那這個我們會從
會從這個
呃
從儲置裡面
然後呢
找股票
那這些呢都會在那個
我們的
課程裡面會交給各位
那我們都是利用這軟體來做的齁
那再跟各位講
我是
我其實以前沒有很認真做
儲置啊
因為我覺得沒有一個好的軟體
讓我認真做嘛
所以呢 欸 這個學員殷切的期盼所以呢 我們跟理財寶合作呢 就寫了一個這軟體自從寫了這個軟體之後我發現 處置真的很好玩真的很好玩
就因為它太好玩了
所以我最近處置呢
就做的比較多一點
做的比較多一點
那從4月
我們剛剛看是從
3月20號開始
那從4月開始來看
這不同數字
4月來看大概是8200
3月大概是賺400多
所以
我發現認真做的話
那這裡面的錢大概放多少
這裡面的錢大概放2000
放2000
然後呢賺8000多
哇 黃婉玲你用的都賠錢喔
那真的很可惜欸
你用的都賠錢你到底是怎麼做的啊
這名字好
好耳熟啊
好像上次用當中神器也賠錢是同一個人
那真的是
喔欸對
我們講一下
對了我們有一個群組齁
要特別講一下我們有這群組
我們這群組的那個
我先給各位看齁
這群組齁
這群組吼 五百個人
目前沒有人退
我們來看一下
我們看這個
五百個人沒有人退
等一下 我先進到這群組
我進到這群組呢 再來
再來看一下
因為這群組我覺得還蠻優秀的
好
來看一下
呃 群組我記得百萬的蠻多的啊
我忘了我上次在那邊回答
我上次回答的時候就一堆百萬的啦
一堆百萬的對張來
先給各位看啊 訊息
這裡這裡
呃來來來
給各位看一下
這邊反正就有很多百萬的獲利對賬單欸群體月薪百萬已經到第六期了嗎
我記得我看到六個以上
喔 看到六個以上
小哥粉絲百萬熊兵
不然不然不然
今天不是賺百萬就是賠百萬
百萬是基本上
月入百萬
所以我記得上次有看到他們很多賺百萬
我下次再把那個群組裡面
我把他貼一下
等一下看一下
我看一下那個小秘書幫我解一下
這裡啊
這邊是處置神器的一些獲利啊
這個
來看
唉唷
小秘書沒有解我上次看到一堆百萬的
就是我們在做
我找一下對話
因為大部分都是他們自己在那邊聊得很開心
聊得很開心啦 所以
我的對話比較少一點
那我看到 上次看到一堆百萬的賬單
在裡面 百萬的很多啦
這我記得百萬的很多 就是
從進來到現在
因為現在就是一個很好做的時機
很好做的時機
那這策略呢 實證就是
特別好 特別好用
特別好用 這真的很好用
這很好用欸 因為 其實很多人在做
很多人在做
很多人在做 所以呢
欸 欸 欸 各位那個貼一下
欸 各位再500群的貼一下
不然
不然我那個
還要在上面找不好找
還是你們貼一貼 我把它截圖一下
哇 資源百萬的
欸 有 有 有 有 有人資源了
來來
這邊資源的齁 來這裡
欸 欸 這裡有啦
9點27分資源
265萬 有看到
喔對喔 我從這邊看
哇這邊是100萬
喔我覺得他們裡面還蠻好玩的
裡面都會
都會那個
自己做一些圖啊
喔 蠻好玩的
欸 看一下
哇 這63萬
課程
看起來 這是裡面的圖啊 我沒有教學
做全職交易的第一些欸 他們蠻有趣的喔喔他們都會自己做圖片出來把一些把一些
把一些那個
重點嗎 整理
有正期望值
那這個交易就是正期望值嗎
我都做給你看了
好不好
就是我們
自從有了做軟體
那我就開始認真做嘛
因為以前沒有很認真做
有了這個軟體之後 我開始認真做
從這個軟體裡面找標的
那怎麼找的方法呢 也交給各位
所以呢 我現在買的股票呢 其實
跟大家都很類似啊 跟大家都很類似
群組更新很多百萬帳單了 看一下看一下
很多百萬帳單的 看一下
這邊 這邊有一個
哇 600多萬
哇塞
太猛太猛
各位看一下 哇這都儲置股啊
各位自己看啊 都儲置股
對
齊邦 景碩 東美金 景碩 京居 見頂
欸這都儲置股啊
金元電 望紅 環球金 納雅克
呃 假如有 不是儲置股的
可能就是他自己想買的
反正這獲利就
就很強啊齁
就很強 全期貨
欸有時候儲置期貨 我有時候買不下去欸
因為有時候儲置期貨真的有夠貴
都是那個
都正價差2% 3% 我真的買不下去
所以這一個群組的向心力很足嘛
因為 因為他們賺很多錢啊
他們 他們這一群是第一群啊
就是我們在3月多的時候
一開賣 他們就加進來
所以呢 他們 你說他有紅利嗎
其實到目前為止還是蠻好做的啦
到目前為止還是蠻好做的
假如有一天不好做我會跟你講
但是到目前為止呢
都好做
再跟各位講到目前為止都好做
因為你看這大盤就知道嘛
大盤長這樣當然好做啊
你懂我意思嗎
大盤長這樣就是好做
那有沒有可能做到賠錢呢
一定有的嘛對不對
來看一下
我處置賠錢的股票
這之前講過了嘛 建設
對不對
那因為
就是
因為我買買在這一天啊
結果呢連續兩根嘛
齁那連續兩根我在這一天呢
我利用空期貨來避險
空期貨來避險
我這邊呢我有空期貨避險
在這邊呢大大的做多
大大的做多
然後反彈之後呢出掉
然後在這一天呢
因為我們的處置日報有寫
它又要被關了
這邊又處置嘛
所以我在這一天選擇全部出清
所以我在這邊是賺錢的喔
我在這裡買
買
空
因為你這邊跌停你要空啊 你要空期貨啊
大大買
賣一點
全出加空
有沒有看到
再講一次喔
我在這裡買嘛
這邊買的張數沒有很多啦
這邊是空 空期貨 不是空限股
因為期貨沒有跌停 限股有跌停
就像台聖科一樣嘛 台聖科
今天一樣啊 台聖科今天一樣
這個限股
現股沒有跌...期貨沒跌停嘛
啊現股有跌停嘛
他有時候會這樣 因為正價差
所以有時候會有這種機會
那
我就利用了空期貨 幣點錢
在這裡是大大買
為什麼要大大買 因為在這邊
出量了嘛 而且連續跌停
沒跌停就要買
再講一次 連續跌停沒跌停就要買嘛
反過來
連續漲停沒漲停就好細啊 你懂嗎
連續漲停沒漲停 當然空它啦
再講一次喔 連續漲停沒有漲停一定空嘛
你看這邏輯是不是一樣
建設是連續跌停沒跌停要買嘛
那台勝客是連續漲停沒漲停要空嘛
一樣嘛 連續漲停
你是鎖不住了 就是有問題了嘛
你懂的是嗎 就有問題了
所以呢 我們就可以知道說
我們就知道他的節奏
連續跌停 沒跌停
出達量 要買進
那連續漲停
台政科我不會補在一間的漲停板
我不會補
小哥那因為你錢多 你撐得住
我說 這不是這樣講
這個是你的資金控管的問題
小哥我就只能做一口 你只能做一口你就不該做台聖科你懂啊你只能做一口 你就別做台聖科了你要去做金額比較小的啊因為你只能做一口 你只能做一口 你就不該做台聖科你懂嗎你只能做一口 你就別做台聖科了你要去做金額比較小的啊因為你只能做一口嘛
你只能做一口
按照我們的教學邏輯是
你每一檔你只能用1.10的資金啊
你懂嗎
每一檔你只能用1.10的資金
再講一次喔 每一檔你只能用1.10
那你在這一檔 如果我只能
我就只能做這一檔 我只能all in
我做了
那我只能做一口all in了
那不行啊 那當然不行啊
你這樣做法一定畢業的啊
為什麼 因為
因為你即便勝率90%
你還會遇到那10%讓你畢業的嘛
那遇到那10%讓你畢業的
你就真的畢業了 你懂嗎
那我們這種分散資金的是
即便我遇到
我都有資金 我可以去找
後援部隊嘛 你懂嗎
我今天有後援部隊啊 我有我可成啊
欸 可成我們不是在直播跟你講
各位 直播室有跟你講 有聽到的加個1
有沒有跟你講 直播的時候有講
這邊的古禁比多少 古禁比0.75
0.75你不買
有沒有跟你講 有跟你講加個1 有聽到這一段句
加個1 有沒有
跟你講0.75你就是要買啊 可成
古徑比0.75 這邊
古徑比0.75 就是給你上車的嘛
這不是N次了
N次0.75 讓你上車嗎
不是N次了
N次
你看
這麼多家印
N次了
我們說你不用理會投信
主頭賣怎麼辦
那是笨蛋
然後主頭信
投信那是笨蛋好不好
這個投信笨蛋
這我們看過很多次了
這投信老師賣的第一點好不好
相信洪水樹明年換別墅好不好
相信洪水樹明年換別墅
可成他布了這局布了多久
再跟你講可成布了這局布了多久
2018年好不好
2018年
他布了這局布了8年了
他自從把那個
這個
他賣掉哪一個
反正在中國把
藍石嗎還是什麼
反正在中國把它賣掉
可成的關鍵分點
在可成的可成的關鍵分點我們找神秘券商神秘券商來
神秘券商為什麼長這樣
神秘券商 照美好熊
他布這局布了8年了
他在2018年
趁著什麼樣 趁著
YOY
再跟各位講一次齁
他們的厲害就在這裡
他趁得歪歪歪
大好之際
大量的幹嘛
大量的出脫可乘
喔 這講一次喔
趁得歪歪歪
大好之際
大量的出脫可乘
然後呢
就疊下來了嘛
然後在這邊呢
一直吃一直吃
他就一直吃那個
庫藏股啊
喔
他吃庫藏股吃了多久啊
我們看1000天
你看1000天還不夠欸
你可能要看2000天
看一下2000天
2000天好像超過了
大概1500
好1500 有啦
招北高雄買了5萬張
元大這也是庫藏股
喔 他這一次的庫藏股
買了4萬張
富邦台南這也是庫產股
懷孟商台南
我們把區間買超找出來
區間買超 富邦台南 招北高雄 元大
這都是啊
台興 浮沉 這也是啊
元大 金華 台南人
台南人 有沒有
台南人
布這個局 布了多少
布了8年了
8年的
好不好
這種大賣之後布了這局
布了8年 我們就說可成你可以存股嘛
那你就安心存
他每年配期都填洗的
沒有一年讓你失望
沒有一年可成沒有填洗的
再講一次 他每年配期都填洗
你去哪裡去找一個這麼高值率的股票
每年都填洗給你
然後呢 跟各位講
這兩根只是剛開始
好不好
這只是剛開始而已
他今天好像盤中要打開
結果又沒打開
害我本來賣掉 我又買回來
我又買回來
我提問他沒有全部買回來
那這個
這只是剛開始
這可誠呢他是有這個步錄AI的AI可誠AI可成 好不好AI可成他是AI可成啦 這剛開始而已啦
他 他布這局布了8年了
8年 好不好
8年 喔 他這個
你可以想像
這兩三年來
應該這一兩年啦
像連AI
長的
可誠都沒有長到
好不好都沒有長到
結果呢
這個
你可以去看
看
他後面怎麼補長
我對他還是蠻看好的
我現在可誠還是多單
還是多單
好
這個
我跟你講
再看學
我們再看對賬單
哇
來來來 你看
講完之後我們的群組紛紛支援
149萬 嘿嘿嘿 搞笑王子
149萬喔
唉唷
這看一下
喔這120萬 這邊有啊 底下有 120萬
我要這樣看
拍這裡
120萬
255萬
哇
讚讚讚
喔
欸
這邊是賠的
應該是
截另外一張圖
看一下
這邊是386萬
386萬
211萬
喔670萬
好
就這樣
喔所以這個
我們群組裡面
賺錢的很多嘛
所以你看我們是
我們是
自己賺錢設計一個好用的軟體
設計一個好用軟體 然後呢
好好的打 因為你總要做給人家看嘛
所以我們為什麼要下這麼多的交易量
為什麼要繳這麼多稅
來來來
這裡喔
我們來看一下喔 這邊 這裡
喔 這邊 這一篇爆了
這邊 這邊超爆的 這邊
5月結算喔
光是這個戶頭
我沒有拿這個戶頭的
欸
這戶頭對阿算我還沒拿出來
光這個戶頭呢手續費487萬
交易稅340萬
379萬 各位你可以算一下
379你去把它乘以12
那因為我不是只有這戶頭
我有8個戶頭
為什麼有8個戶頭 因為
這個各家的券不一樣
有時候要去要券
這個戶頭算是主要的戶頭
光這個月交易稅就379
各位你把它乘以12
然後你再加上其他戶頭
所以一年貢獻個五千萬
是沒什麼問題
沒什麼問題
那因為我們貢獻這麼多證交稅嘛
所以去年是稅收超增
全民普發一萬
那我跟各位講
按照今年的量
我覺得全民普發兩萬不為過
全民普發兩萬不為過
看完這些帳單處置是不是賣太便宜
不會啦 不會
我覺得
這個
反正大家用的開心比較重要
用的開心比較重要
看到大家賺錢 小哥開心了
當然開心
哇 因處置神器本金300萬
各位看一下
因處置神器
本金300萬以實現700萬 未實現300萬
哇塞
其中未實現包含拖後腿的建設
哎呦 建設還沒處理完
那建設你假如低檔加碼的話應該是大賺
所以你看這個300 700 300
哇 賺了300又賺了
又賺了1000多了欸
300賺1000欸 真的很強欸
出家小哥賣
不是 我敲開了 我是賣漲停
因為我覺得他快要那個
他快要敲開了 我想說我敲開
我先敲開我再把他買回來
想不到居然買不回來
還有我期望有買回來
還有期望買回來
可曾搞得我從少女變成少婦
好不好 少女變少婦
好啦
好 來來來 所以
所以這個
你看我們繳這麼多歲 各位啊 你去哪邊
聽一個直播一年繳五千萬證交稅的人直播啊他繳有一年繳五千萬證交稅直播你一定要跟我講我一定要去聽因為人家一定有很多交易心得
不管是賺錢賠錢
就像我們賠錢也會跟你講啊對不對
賠錢跟你講嘛
對不對3653的建設
對不對
這個就賠錢嘛
就是在這段賠錢啦
但是後面是賺錢的
這個剛剛講的3532的台勝科
我現在看還有做誰賠錢
我發現我每次做處置賠錢喔
大部分是怎麼樣 大部分都是那個
呃 絕對來說 和聲塔
我做處置賠錢 大部分都是做空
大部分都是做空賠錢 所以我常常跟學員講
欸你可以不要空就不要空
你看這和聲塔幾乎也沒什麼低頭啊
他大概只有低頭這一天而已
幾乎沒有低頭
每天的那個每次儲置都
都上漲
每次儲置都上漲
真的太猛了
這很猛
所以這個儲置做空這個
真的很危險
所以我們講你可以不要做不要做
所以我們基礎的第一招
就是浪子回頭嘛
浪子回頭找買點嘛
那你真的要空的話
你一定要做個雙刀好不好
好不好
那我們現在處置我們不只做這些
我們還做套利
喔 處置可以做套利
這處置套利超好套
超好套 我跟你講
我這個
股市
我在股市裡面
從2000年到現在
已經26年
我沒有看過
沒有看過
有一年的套利
像今年這麼好做
你知道為什麼嗎
為什麼沒有一年的套利
像今年這麼好做呢
然後呢 重要的原因就是
資金的成本太高了
資金成本太高了 我不說多的
光台積電我可以無風險套
幾乎無風險 激進無風險
我們之後呢 我們假如找到一個
可以讓我找到一個特殊的單位
幫我們做組合單的話
我大概可以套個20% 30%不是問題
20% 30% 但是我現在還沒找到這個單位
還沒找到
有找到呢
有找到
有找到也不能跟你講
因為這個是秘密
不能跟你講就是有太多東西可以套在講的時候有太多東西可以套喔 在講的時候有太多東西可以來做 可以套的所以處置呢 他有太多好玩的了
喔 太多好玩的
喔 所以 這麼好玩的東西
你可以選擇不學嘛 可以
再見 再見
反正小哥都GAY好不好
小哥都要這樣假的 那個群組都要這樣假的
大家都假的 都要假的
你可以不相信 再見 再見
因為我們
我們真的不缺啦 我們真的不缺
對 那個
來看一下
彩晶也真的蠻猛的
以為處置會稍微回檔 也沒有回檔
一直往上漲
真的很猛 所以
這個
套利方向決算自由以下
錯!套利不一定要到結算
盤中有機會就解掉了
我在昨天呢
我在昨天
環球金
環球金我昨天
期貨空到1005
現貨買到950
厲害吧
再講一次喔
期貨空到105還1000
忘了1000跟105
差不多
現貨買到950
昨天盤中環球金呢
就讓我正價差弄了50塊
喔 50塊
環球金有50塊喔
今天盤中
盤中你解你可以解到剩5塊
喔 今天盤中的環球金可以解到剩5塊
喔 大概是
大概在這一盤
這一盤
喔 這盤剩4塊
聽懂嗎
呵呵呵呵
比夜市套圈圈好套
沒有錯
呵呵 講得很好
比夜市套圈圈才是難
好不好 這套力超簡單
超簡單的
你不想套別套好不好
不要 我們這個套力最討厭大家來套
來套人多我們還不好套
還不好套
楊誠出冠是處置了例外嗎
出冠那天偶爾也會變這樣
偶爾變這樣
所以楊誠算是比較弱的
有TOLYQ的可以上嗎 你去看那個啊
這個古奇克啊 古奇克就有TOLY啊上帽沒辦法空啦上帽沒辦法空這個我們在上一次的直播就跟你講了嘛上一次直播是不是有講
是不是
是不是有講
有講的加一
有沒有
我們上次不是有跟你講
我說賭股票你不能買啦
這個也不能空啦
你不要去買好不好
各位有聽到這一段加個一
我聽到這一段加個一
就跳這一段
這有股票你會怎麼樣
你會買不到X3
買到了X3
賣不掉X3
你懂啊
這股票就這樣子嘛
這我們看過很多了嘛
買不到X3
賣不掉X3
我跟各位講
這個有趣的是這樣子
這個上茂呢
他假如連續跌停個六七根的話
欸?
那個爆量會蠻好玩的
爆量會蠻好玩的
假如連續跌停六七根的話
我們來看一下
來看一下現在亮多少
唉唷
唉唷 這個亮
這要連續跌停六七根的話呢
會蠻好玩的
好啦 我們再觀察一下
每天記得
怕我忘記
先把上帽
先加入自選
我嚇我忘記
這個每天漲停跟跌停大概都要看一下
明天
明天股票要看一下
64886182
這幾個
我現在看有什麼
杏昌店
有的很多都要留意一下
還有3008
欸各位啊
我們講他308好不好
招衛忠利為什麼買生威人員
他每次都看這種事啊
他看過兩次的啊
欸 生威幾齁
生威人員他看過兩次了
最近我的
生威680
他看過兩次了好不好
造物在這裡啊 唉唷 賣不掉囉
喔 出事了喔
今天4%可能買不去啊
他幹過兩次了 這邊不是幹過一次嗎
你看這個點子抓到多少
對不對
這裡買這裡賣
齁 哇
他可能
呃...不知道
不知道這次怎麼賣齁
這次可能抓到齁
齁 這次可能抓到齁
齁
大力光啊
我們講一下
大力光的股價有點委屈啊
有點委屈啊
這跟各位講的
他的股價還是委屈
還是委屈
喔 近世紀可以賺157塊
你現在賺他本益比也沒幾倍
好不好
20倍
大概挺多20幾倍而已
他的股價我覺得還是委屈
然後呢 他要出關了
他要出關了 大力光出關了
那這個同樣的位置類似的叫做聯發科
聯發科啊
那連發哥呢
這個跌下來
出關之後 他出關之後呢
是繼續漲的喔
因為
出關之後他就比較自由一點
所以連發哥出關之後繼續漲
那大力光我覺得他這個股價
對他而言喔
假如是AI題材裡面
那對這個股價而言呢
我覺得有點委屈啦
那這個三多哥呢
三多哥呢他
他最近呢 還有在追
最近還有在追喔
那你說 三多哥是這個
追多嗎 不是啦 是因為他買太多了
被他買上去了 只要一買的那一天
那個股價都很強 好不好
他是不大會
不大會怎麼樣 他不大會那個
被他買上去的喔
因為他的量太大了
所以我覺得
主要是因為量大所以常被他買上去
是這個原因
好
我們先講一下
先講一下這裡
今天這個QRK各位可以加一下
這個PP有九折優惠券
這裡有九折優惠券
你訂看看就知道了好不好
你訂看看你覺得
90在猜 猜多少錢啊
800多塊
你就第一個月看看
你覺得不好你就把它退掉不好你就把它退掉裡面呢 有很多學學問股票的一些心得昨天有人特別問連帽
還好他有問
我今天就主要空連帽
今天我就空連帽
連帽這個值得空啊 各位你看一下
那個籌碼事實上沒有很好
籌碼沒有很好 然後又怎麼樣
然後昨天買的分點又是誰
土城永齡啊 哇 凹丹哥啊
他今天就要凹了 好不好
土城永齡 凹丹哥
福哥要唱歌
這東西
吼 這是土城永齡 凹丹哥 我以為他今天會出勒
吼 那我今天就空聯邦 因為聯邦今天弱嘛
那凡是弱的呢 有企圖往上拉的我都空他
吼 就這一段 這裡
弱了 往上拉 都空他
喔 弱了 往上拉 空它
喔 所以各位 各位呢 你可以來做這一種
喔 弱了往上拉的空
喔 好
那各位可以加一下這幾個QR quote
喔 這個特館粉絲團呢 會公告一些事項
官方社團交易的這個
官方社團有交易的知識 YouTube 教學影片
IG呢 偶爾會貼那個當充點位圖啊
那我們今天就貼個當充點位圖
唉唷 今天
今天我看他急拉我去空
因為他有一些隔日充阿
然後沙下有補掉 還好有補喔
沒補真的是
沒補被
被嘎爆
沒補被嘎爆
來來來 這裡
哇 這個是那個
上次的
上次的那個影片阿
這邊就夾了很多娃娃
所以我們這個處置神器呢
就是用浪子回頭來做股票
浪子回頭做股票
好 那我們今天呢 我們就
欸 這裡看一下
等一下 我的圖 我看一下
我今天
我有貼在這邊啊
我貼在這裡
喔 還好有回補這裡
這裡啊
還好有回補 哇賽這沒補了 被嘎爆喔 這個空在邊嘛 然後回補在這裡後面拉長點了 還好有回補
沒補的話 今天被動的
這個尾盤真的還蠻強的
後面的盤是很強
夜盤快500點 很兇 欸不錯不錯
反正我還是很多多單啊
再跟各位講
目前我們的策略是這樣
就是這樣
只要盤中看到有利潤可以套的
我的做法是這樣
我會用七成的多單
因為可以套多單都是正價差嘛
所以可以套我就七成多單
加三成空單
去套
所以呢我就是三成多跟三成空
這兩個套做套利
有四成做多
因為現在這種行情
你一定要跟著他瘋啊
再跟各位講
這種行情你一定要跟著他瘋
你沒跟著他封你 賺不到
你唯一要擔心的是
萬一有一天有一個20%的回檔
你要撐得住
那按照我們的做法
我們七成多單 三成空單
那三成空單可以在
20%的回檔好好保護我
所以那時候我一定撐得住
再講一次喔
那時候我是一定撐得住的
一定撐得住
那時候我絕沒問題
那因為我撐得住
瘋狂做多 再跟各位講
你現在要瘋狂做多啊
現在這種AI的
AI現在這個齁
這個我是覺得比工業革命還厲害
再跟各位講
AI這個是比工業革命還厲害
比工業革命還厲害
為什麼 因為你現在你叫AI做任何事情
你覺得天啊 他做的比太多人做的好太多了
這個根本不是一般人可以做的到的
反正你有什麼問題都可以問他
那未來呢 未來有可能怎麼樣
未來AI再進化到後面
我猜啊 未來一定會走到生計
反正AI後面就全部都拉一輪
未來會走到生計怎麼樣呢
以後AI可能就可以把那個
把癌症當成感冒
感冒
我覺得未來
AI呢
有機會把癌症當感冒
所以各位你現在一定要好好的養生
把自己照顧好
這個不要不要輕易的掛掉不要輕易的掛掉自己身體照顧好未來呢未來你有什麼問題
那AI呢
大概率可以幫你解決
所以呢
這個AI這個太厲害了
好
來
講到這邊請各位加QR
講了老半天
這邊喔
欸
討論群4個8
好不好 4個8
可以活到150歲喔
我覺得很有可能
喔
我搭討女朋友的方法靠AI幫我想的問題
真的
喔這個AI
其實
真的很厲害啊
AI主要生地加4打喔
我4個8
4個8
喔密碼4個8喔
各位加一下
4個8
這邊呢我會定期的復盤
有什麼交易心得會撥在上面
資訊分享啊解惑專區啊
大部分裡面都有很多
這個熱心的學長姐會回答
會回答
然後詐騙呢半夜4 5點會出現
可以給我講一次
半夜4 5點會出現
他會假冒
假冒我跟小秘書
然後怎麼樣
然後說要創一個新群
喔這老梗啦
我說你
那個被騙的就被騙好了啦
因為你也不適合做股票
你還是被騙好了
好
各位這加一下
加一下
好那我們今天要講處置神器
處置神器真的是
蠻好用的
好然後現在有web版
web版就是有網頁版的
我有網頁版可以用囉
所以各位呢這個除此神器你除了用手機以外也可以用網頁看
也可以用網頁看
啊
來看一下
你看這邊寫
呃
欸?這邊
不想要買除此神器就別買了
不要買
有買的自己賺得很爽就好
對啊
通知中心語音功能
通知中心語音功能可以用
中心的運運功能可以用
運運功能可以用
來
那這個儲置神器呢可以幫你做什麼呢
它會預測儲置日報
然後呢會有儲置股的監控
那你知道說哪些股票呢會有壓力
然後它有獨家統計的功能
這統計功能其實我覺得非常好用
那重點就是告訴你怎麼樣
其實大部分都長這樣啦
就是儲置呢你就要積極做多啦
再講一次喔
儲置的時候你要積極做多
積極做多好不好
積極做多
那這個裡面
它是有含
基礎處置策略啊進階處置策略
雙刀戰法策略每月實戰陪跑
雙刀討論群組
然後它又有一些
像我們上次在台北
政大公企中心的課程
它把它剪成已經放進去了
所以這裡面的通通價值
是蠻高的而且是越來越高
因為裡面有很多
很多那個交易的心得都在裡面嘛
你去哪邊去找那種
一年繳稅五千萬的跟你講這些啦
要嘛就講一次就不講了
好不好
就是厲害的講一次
你就沒看到他再出現了嘛
對不對
就有一些厲害的嘛
講一次就沒有了
或者是
厲害的就去大學講一講
你也找不到他了
所以現在
欸
你可以找到有人跟你分享
然後可以量這麼大的
很少啦齁
好啦 那24小時限時發揮軟體加課程呢
是這個價錢啦 我目前今天只要
喔 加送一個月軟體全線1400喔
買Weber送APP是5萬2
總價值20萬 然後今天只要45000
齁 直播限定
那24小時之後他就
他就漲了 好不好
然後你20小時之後就不要再問我
因為一直都有人問說有沒有處置
打折啊 每次打折完都有人問
什麼時候還要再打折
我說我不確定 只要
處置還有
還有做我們就有機會再打折
假如處置不好做我們就可能就沒有打折了
好 那我們這個下禮拜呢
這禮拜
這禮拜在台中廠的出現期課程
還有高廠的出現期課程
這個這禮拜的
欸台中已經誇滿了
誇滿了
我昨天看好像剩下十幾個
今天不知道剩幾個
好
我們先來看上週的小名單當初就是覺得小哥用簡單白話的方式來分享交易方法不同時期有不同的交易模式
小哥就不希望產後小真主賠錢
所以才在市場上交易分享
怕真的很多
除非行情可轉載動態套利結論樂透除止辦法爽到賺法
剛好出國不安全的市場投資吧
看了看市面
市場檯面上就沒有第二位願意這樣分享實在經營老師
真的
嗯
喔
好
股市利害的人很多
在像小哥這樣願意把真正的觀念50分享
一路把大家從規準
大家開始相信自己能犯人真的很少
你每天分享那些內容
對很多人來說不只是股票
更在地潮裡重新相信未來的希望
真的很借一直都在
搭配組成1號做股票
真的會看到全境口袋
真的啦
喔真的會進口袋啊
而且我們
我們教的方法有很多
有很多
我跟你講
我這次的外資發文包
光講外資發文包
這是賺翻的
這裡啊
說錯了
新星啊
各位看一下
外資發紅包
這裡啊
這個外資發紅包這一篇
五月底嘛
這是我們那個文章都寫得很清楚啦
五月底外資就要發紅包
這個6600張
我吃了1000張
我吃了1000多張
不是1000張而已
吃了一千多張
我是市場上吃最大的
我市場上吃最多的
第二多的是松山哥
他吃的比我少一點
我們兩個吃最多
吃最多
那這個方法
這個人家想教嗎
不想教啊 教你這幹嘛
對不對 教你這個
隔音漲停
教這一招
六千張還要跟你分
對不對
我都吃一千張了 他吃五百張
那剩下就是
其他的人吃到
那我們那一天呢
我們那一天也
也那個也跟
也跟我們線上講
趕快買趕快買
外資發紅包 領紅包了
不只他 我還吃到誰你知道嗎
我還吃到
國具
各位看一下
這紅包
我買到25張
外資發紅包25張
然後隔天咧 各位你看隔天又漲停 有沒有看到外資發紅包啊我是賣在上面喔賣在上面 我沒有開盤就賣 我賣在上面
因為我覺得那個
那個期貨真的是
蠻強的
各位你去看PBPPP有講好不好
PB講了很多次啊
你就把外資發紅包找出來
裡面講得很清楚
外資怎麼發紅包
不只他啊 我跟各位講
很多檔
那天很多檔 還有誰
喔 那天 我 這次的紅包是我有生以來啊
有生以來吃過最多的
喔 有生以來吃過最多的
我 想看還有誰
我找一下
我那天有截圖啊
這5月29號的紅包
沒有吃過這麼多的紅包
喔 真的沒有
沒有一次吃的這麼爽的
因為那天的紅包太多了
我找一下
因為那天的紅包
我看一下我查一下
我查一下昨天的對帳單就知道了
這個紅包真的是很好玩
外資發紅包
還有一個734
應人科技
你自己看
你以為紅包只有
只有那個減嗎
沒有
這裡啊
這邊好像中六張
對六張
六張
外資發紅包六張
這裡
登登
這個是空啊
這空喔
那後面疊
後面疊
這外資
這紅包我吃的超
超多
吃到就有點不好意思
反正
他們就這樣
他們就喜歡這樣亂賣啊
我有什麼方法
他們就是要這樣賣白目
還有那個啊 3008
3008好像
應該有點像對不對 308也是308也是喔 只是他的那個%數沒那麼多還有2454也是
2454也是
還有2395啊
各位你看2395
哇超優惠啊
超優惠的價格給你
有沒有
超優惠
前一天495賣給你 隔天517隨便賣
千差沒
好不好
外資放包 你去看PP啦
PP又是什麼
PP是什麼
不知道PP的在這裡好不好
在這裡PP這裡
這邊這邊這邊
這邊好不好
欸我跟各位講欸
這個一般人
賺那麼多不想教你啊
教你幹嘛
我賺那麼多我教你我就是分你而已啊
你懂嗎 我教你我只是分你
我做這麼多 然後
賺那麼多我教一個就是
我就少賺一個
教一個少賺一個你知道嗎
已經這樣子了 我現在教你 為什麼
你就來跟我搶紅包啦
你就來跟我搶紅包 你懂啊
他發紅包有限嘛
所以我們剛剛講那個2605
我已經
你有看過有人
我在市場上我已經買最多了欸
市場上我買最多的
買最多的我還教你來搶這紅包
你知道嗎
我是市場上買最多的
我在這一檔我賺最多的
那我還教你說欸這檔這個值得買喔
趕快來買
還教你
結果教了你之後呢
欸各位你想想看
交這個事實上是有可能會有一些不好的事情會發生
舉例來說啦
這個價格會被你們買上去啊
我交完之後這個會被你們買上去嘛
你就是買30.2
有人進來就搶30.3 30.4
就被買上去了 我可能就買不到啦
所以我交了之後我只會讓我不好買
然後隔天會讓我不好賣啊
你看這搞不好價格就被人家砍下來
還好我撐久一點
我撐久一點
我有的也是在上面賣掉
所以這種
這種招式
尤其這種很短線的招式
其實很多人不想教啊
你知道嗎不想教
好
所以在這種公開
我們還是不能交
不能交啦
交下去還得了
交下去以後沒飯吃
我們有很多種賺錢的方法
那我們就是盡量把我們
懂得會的可以賺錢的方法
我們就交給你啦
交給你
就希望你可以賺錢啦
來看一下
哇 這個蠻感人的喔
來 這個
呃
新加富2046
非常謝謝小哥去年對等關稅賠到心態崩潰
先看了小哥的書重新建立起正確的交易心態
訂了PP在針對不足買線上課上子底課
今年已經把去年賠的300萬都贏回來了
300萬
太棒了300萬厲害厲害了
去年贏回來
我跟你講小哥有考慮開投資公司
欸我這還真的蠻想開投信公司的
假如我可以 以後我可以開投信公司
我們是
我們發行00500
好不好00500 不是0050
0050算什麼 我們發00500
好不好 每季多500
發行0050
為什麼 因為這個0050有很多種可以用
0050有很多種東西可以用啊
各位你看它配齊啊 配齊一塊0.36
我發行的話 每季多配500
每季多配0.5
報價跟他類似
我們這個群名00500
目標就是幹掉他而已
目標幹掉他
為什麼可以幹掉他 簡單嘛
財務司 你去買0050個股期貨就好啦
剩下錢拿去幹嘛 剩下錢拿去瘋狂的做一些
穩健獲利 做一些套利的嘛
你去把一些錢套出來
套出來 然後你這個直接買050期貨就好
你只要買0.5.7
你連那50檔都不用買
連那50檔都不用買
齁
啊這個
這...這個就這樣啊
再給各位看一個東西啊
你以為
這個我們之前有說過齁
元大台灣50正二
大家吵得沸沸癢癢
一堆人在吵元大台灣50正二
你到底知道嗎你到底知道嗎你到底知道嗎來看一下元大50震惡你到底知道元大50政二也行嗎你到底知道嗎來看一下元大50政二
這裡啊
你要績效盈元大50政二
困難嗎
我們看一下喔
我們看一下困不困難
基金檔案
欸 看一下看一下
我找一下
欸
投資組合 欸有投資組合怎麼沒有寫
嗯...等一下我猜一下
我猜...這上次...上次我們在講那個元大50真的
你可以看一下他的...他的那個
有啊
哇你看這超長的
上次就特別講嘛
你看
元大ETF陝型證券投資信託基金
是台灣50單向正向
兩倍投資信託基金
樂樂等元大50
單向兩倍基金
哇大家看到兩倍基金
喔 台北
吵來吵去
這個說0050
那個說真惡好
這個說真惡不好
吵來吵去
那你要不要看一下它的持股叫什麼
喔你看
來看一下他的持股叫什麼
他的持股
他的股票
股票的台積電
期貨的台灣期貨
沒了
沒了 有看到
你差到要死
台灣50振二倍
台灣50各買兩倍
那個0050的買兩倍
沒有
呵呵呵
買什麼而已 買台股期貨
買3萬塊
買台積電那一年啊
就買這樣子而已
其他都幹嘛 其他都跑去買
付買回債券
啊你
你買
你買元大50台
你買元大真的
你自己去買台子期貨的
自己去買台子期貨
然後再買台積電
結案
這樣就結案了嘛
這樣就結案了 所以
這正好跟什麼
我跟你講你買台股旗啦
正15好不好
台股旗正15現在看看可能低一點 可能正14正14 它是元大台灣50 正14 好不好
你剩下錢
剩下錢幹嘛 自己做套利
要什麼正二 你就
去買台子期
來 去買台子期就好
然後呢
這個 把你的錢
剩下的 好不好
你現在買0050也不用買了啦
你就去買台子旗
買0050個股旗 都可以
你就開個槓桿嘛
然後把剩下的錢
拿來做套利嘛
欸 拿來做套利
各位啊 我們的旗線或套利
你要不要看一下
每天旗線或套利
這麼肥這麼香
這裡正價差 逆價差
每天這麼肥 信倉電3%
3.8% 財經2.4%
每天這麼香的正義加差 你不套
對不對 你就覺得買0050好像很厲害
我有一堆方法幹掉0050
有一堆方法幹掉0050
我們就買0050的個股旗
把剩下的錢拿來做套利
那不就幹掉它了嗎 對不對
我就買0050個股旗
把一些把剩下的錢拿去買可轉載
因為可轉載你就去買那個不會倒的嘛 對不對
去精挑細犬不會倒了
那大概率就是往上
那你不是幹掉他的嗎
所以呢
現在訂閱PB能看到以前文章跟教學都可以
都看得到
自己買就好了
還沒有管理別人
對啊 本來就自己買就好了
炒咖啡戲
吵來吵去
有什麼好吵的
連吵都不想跟他們吵
你自己可以做得比他好 好不好
再跟各位講 在這交易市場上
你自己都可以做得比他好
你假如不知道怎麼做的 你就跟著我 好不好
都可以給你看對賬單
不只給你看對賬單 還給你看
學員的對賬單
你不相信我 你可以相信學員嗎
那你小哥 你的圖是批的
我給我這動畫給你看
保證不是批的嘛 對不對
所以我們是全部都是真實的
所以市場上攻擊我們假對象單的就
幾乎沒有
以前有啦
現在直接用動畫動態的就沒有了好好 就這樣子啦好 所以最後呢最後的最後最後的最後有需要交易筆記本的
歡迎各位訂閱啦
然後呢我的課
除全席課在前面
除全席課
這裡
6.5號 這快滿了
那最後呢 喜歡今天直播
歡迎按讚訂閱
我們已經快要9萬訂閱了
快9萬訂閱了
留意關心的抽級別花開軟體
現場QA時間不要走開後面會有軟體
好
那各位聽得意猶未盡的話
明天我們還有另外一場直播
這場直播呢是世紀戰法的課的直播
明天這個晚上一樣9點
9點呢
還有另外一個直播
但是這個就有買世紀客的人才會有連結
好啦就這樣子
喜歡今天直播歡迎按讚訂閱留意關心的抽級別花開軟體
現場QA時間不要走開
後面會有抽獎
好 那我們今天的
今天的題目是
除了行行全攻略台北場
是幾號上課
台北場幾號上課
超死的
小編要下班
台北場齁
幾號上課
這個
啊 各位 這個 我們來抽一下
好 出來了 1跟4
1跟4喔
好 以上就是今天的直播啦
非常謝謝各位的觀看
唉唷
我的旅遊怎麼變成麻將座了
麻將座都買好了
麻將座都買好了 我們買
我們買 欸好像買這一款
欸等一下
欸不是 我們買這款
買這款的麻將座
灰眼
好
好 以上 今天的直播啦
各位這個 沒有回答到問題的
不好意思啦 因為今天
這個很多 很多東西
要講 一直講不完
那反正跟各位講
處置真的很好玩啦
真的很好玩
趕緊學啦
〔此段辨識失敗，約 1:20:00 起〕